if we got into a firefight and some
civilians got injured we would allow
them to come into the base we patch them
up and we give them US Dollars sort of
silly really kind of blunt compensation
tool and this was kind of when I really
early on learned that lesson of be very
careful what you measure and the way in
which you incentivize people because
after a while we started to get the same
girl coming in over and over again and
the boss that's down and said you know
you guys haven't been in a firefight
there's been no contact in the area in
the last two a few days I'm right in
thinking that yeah I'm just nothing no
fights in the Taliban okay so why is
this girl coming in refresh gunshot
wounds on the closer inspection we
realize that they're not five five six
rounds they're seven six two so it's not
ah
it's unlikely to be our weapon systems
that are causing these and what we found
out was that this girl's family were
effectively shooting her bringing her in
and using as a cash cow to make money
and then when we realized the game was
up we weren't doing this anymore they
shot her with an RPG and she came in
with no lower jaw and I remember
thinking like a couple of things a it's
an accident of history to be born in the
UK and how lucky I am and be I don't
understand this place
I'm joined by Roderick Yap former Royal
Marines officer now moved into business
so we're gonna be talking about some of
your background today also about how
that's translated across into this new
the new world that you've stepped into
one that's even more dangerous even more
vicious than the one that urine before
Roderick welcome to the show thanks very
much Chris very happy to be looking
forward to speaking to you so give us a
bit of background what what's your
heritage where do you come from and what
did you do
so my first career was as an officer in
the Royal Marines I left University in
2003 2004 struggling to ramada really
with an aspiration to do sort of
something completely different and I
remember there are a number of reasons
that sort of you know calls me to go
down that route but fundamentally it
really was sort of seeking the challenge
and trying to do something that was
different
and I found in life that you know if you
if you're faced with a series of sort of
paths choose the one that's the most
difficult because then you've got to
learn the most about yourself and
ultimately that's that's what I chose to
do so I joined up in 2005 I served for
seven years I was lucky enough to go to
Afghanistan got civilians out of Libya
in 2011 during the Arab Spring and then
towards the end of my time specialized
in counter piracy and did a couple of
tours off the coast of Somalia in the
Indian Ocean so I had an absolutely
fantastic time left
when I turned 34 a sort of a number of
reasons primarily kind of domestic got
married in my final year didn't really
want to be an absent parent and have
since then been working in the corporate
world before starting my own business
why did you say fortunate enough to go
to Afghanistan because I think whilst I
did choose to join the Royal Marines I
joined at a time where the operational
tempo was really really significant you
know we were going we were doing sort of
back-to-back tours of a really demanding
environment and I think that I consider
myself lucky to have been out to those
places being tested in that environment
because I think I'd have found it really
frustrating if I'd gone through training
and then frankly dumbest sort of series
of exercise is or prepared for a war
that wasn't going to happen you know
within 12 months of passing out training
I was being shot at and being tested in
a really hostile dividing environment so
I consider myself lucky to have been
there done that but also survived it and
come out the other side yeah I get there
there's not many people I know that
would have said lucky for being selected
to be shot at in Afghanistan it's it's a
sort of slightly strange way of looking
at it but I mean that there are a number
of people that you know that I sort of
work with even now sort of former raw
Marines officers you know who joined the
Corps in the sort of 90s and didn't and
weren't lucky enough to kind of
experience that you know they were maybe
going to Ireland which wasn't as sort of
kinetic and as aggressive as sort of
Afghanistan and Iraq so they were just
just because of the political situation
they didn't get the chance to to go and
experience it and and I was lucky like
that
so talk me through what it's like coming
out of university because I had a bunch
of friends as well who were in OTC when
they were at uni Officer Training Corps
and they had the potential or maybe I'll
go Sandhurst maybe I do whatever what's
it like being a student and you know
going out on the lash a few nights a
week like most of the people that all of
us know if we went to uni with them and
I am a see what rugby on Saturday stuff
like that and then you know within how
long is it before you're on tour two
years yeah about that although for some
it was much shorter because of the way
the rotations worked guys joined up as
civilians in August 2005 and by
Christmas 2006 they were on the front
line leading 30 guys [ __ ] the bed and I
was like like you know you look at every
other grad scheme right you look at what
who WC Deloitte all these other
companies offer you you tell me one
right that gives you 15 months of
leadership training in some fairly
demanding circumstances and your first
job is lying managing 30 people in
combat as long as there's no one that
offers any level of development anywhere
near that
that's an interesting analogy away a way
to draw it across yeah you would I mean
again one of my housemate that actually
was in the OTC JT he went throughout
Union 21 and did the LD graduate scheme
okay and that's like widely regarded as
you know sort of one of the toughest
ones that you can do but he was being
shot at fifteen months later true it's
but if you think of it like that you
know if you think of you know when
you're in your 20s you've got an
opportunity to take risk
you know because frankly you haven't
been playing the game long enough for it
really to matter so you know even if you
join the army you join the Marines you
decide it's not for you you can always
join a graduate scheme twelve months
later you know you're not gonna be
significantly behind anyone over the
course of a forty fifty year career or
whatever that is so yeah I was I loved
it
you know I look back on it being proud
to have served it made me the person I
am today
it informed a huge amount of the way and
I think and sort of see the world this
strength so I think sometimes
limitations to that but I wouldn't
change a single thing about it do you
think some form of conscription or some
form of more encouraged sign up would be
useful for a lot of people love young
people no so I wouldn't I'm not a
believer in any form of sort of
conscription I'd I think it's really
expensive and also you end up with an
enormous number of people in the
military that finally don't want to be
there but I am in favor of some form of
national service so you know you come
out of university or just before we go
to university there are enough problems
in the UK but you could take a group of
people and so right you you can either
join the military or you could work in
this charitable area you know push
people out of their comfort zone get
them dealing with people that come from
a completely different background
completely different part of the UK you
know when you talk to people and I've
spoken to a few people from Israel they
they really talk about their national
service and in that instance that is
military when they talk about it with a
real sort of sense of pride and they
hugely value the skills and the change
in perspective that they get from it
so it doesn't have to be military but I
do think the
some form of sort of you know voluntary
or military or you you would get to
choose an avenue to go down I think that
would be genuinely a good thing the
people that I know that are in the
nurses the doctors that working in
health care that are working in the law
enforcement in across the world all of
these all of these people have a
perspective that I think unfortunately
those of us who have only ever worked in
an office or you know run our own
business or being an entrepreneur I I
think that I have a good perspective on
the world because I've traveled to
different places to go and have a party
holiday I don't know I I haven't met the
locals of you know Afghanistan I haven't
really I've been to step foot in that
direction once and it was Dubai like
that's not a representative example of
what that area of the world's like and I
think you know that in any any
perspective is useful the more extreme
we can go to the more sort of you
realize kind of how lucky that you are
when I sir was so when I was in
Afghanistan at 2007 we would basically
have this really sort of strange routine
whereby if we got into a firefight and
some civilians got injured we would
allow them to come into the base we
patch them up and we give them US
dollars it's a sort of a sort of a
really kind of blunt compensation tool
and this was kind of what I really early
on learned that lesson of be very
careful what you measure and the way in
which you incentivize people because
after a while we started to get the same
girl coming in over and over again and
the boss saw that style and said you
know you guys haven't been in a
firefight there's been no contact in the
area in the last two a few days I'm
right in thinking that yeah how I said
nothing no fights in the Taliban okay so
why is this girl coming in refresh
gunshot wounds on the closer inspection
we realize that they're not five five
six rounds they're seven six - so it's
not our it's unlikely to be our weapon
systems that are causing these
and what we found out was that this
girl's family were effectively shooting
her bringing her in and using as a cash
cow to make money and then when we
realized the game was up we weren't
doing this anymore they shot her with an
RPG and she came in with no lower jaw
and I remember thinking like couple of
things
fucking-a it's an accident of history to
be born in the UK and how lucky I am and
B I don't [ __ ] understand this place I
cannot understand I cannot relate my
values from where I come from and now as
a father about six-year-old daughter
their three-year-old son I cannot get my
head round how someone can make that
decision and I I think the most the way
I kind of rested with it or sort of
where I got to was that it's unhelpful
to think of some of these places in
terms of geography and some people will
probably kick back on some of these
things I say I think this is I think of
things in in terms of is it useful or
not so much and I think of Afghanistan
frankly as a country much like the
Middle Ages think of Britain you know in
a sort of feudal system and you're
probably not too far wrong and
ultimately that helps you understand it
a little bit more that's how they behave
that's that's just the way it means it's
just that level of development it's more
like traveling back in time than it is
like traveling to a different part of
the world so yeah or Iman Wow
you're right I have no values that I can
extrapolate out I have no working model
of human nature human behavior that I
can expand to make that story make sense
exactly and then so right so now if
that's the context that you're faced
with now effectively deliver a change
program fast track 800 years worth of
development inside
four to six years that's the scale of a
task and and you just realize that you
know you go there for six months and and
you just can't really get your head
round it because you don't really have
any of the mental models any of the
concepts to understand how they think it
is so far removed you might as well go
to the moon and try and have some sort
of impact there it's just a different
planet have you reflected on why is so
different is it just emerging is it
because of a lack of contact with the
outside world this is me speaking as
someone who really doesn't understand
sort of why the culture of Afghanistan
comes from what's the reason for it
being that backward I haven't read it
but I think something you know like
prisoners of geography probably shines a
bit of a sort of view on that Afghan is
of us Afghanistan's a very sort of
mountainous in a very kind of isolated
place
it doesn't I don't think it's got the
same sort of you know inward outward
migration that say you know you know
Europe has I don't think it's had the
same concept yeah I don't have the same
access even things as simple as someone
was saying to me you know animals that
you're able to domesticate you know we
take that for granted in Europe but that
has had a significant impact on on how
we've been able to fight effectively you
know move you know you take something
like a horse right
we take horses for granted in Europe and
sort of this part the world they sort of
fairly able to kind of survive here but
you know you take something like a zebra
and a zebra can't be tamed so you know
how that has an impact I kind of don't
know but I suspect it's kind of those
kind of things a kind of cumulative
impact of a lot of things one of them
being climate you know access to a
variety of sort of different cultures
that can cross pollinate the ability to
grow different crops to be you know
anywhere near so something like the Li
enlightenment taking place that probably
never really got there and so
recent yeah these kind of things it's
interesting to talk about the
cosmopolitan sort of thing I don't see
any students saying I'm gonna go and do
my gap year in like Baghdad or no no
like that they're not sending themselves
over there so it is and then bizarrely
there's two sides to it right there's
part of me that wants to look at that
story and say what [ __ ] savages Wow
how dare you do that to someone and then
on the flip side of that I think well
would you have said the same thing about
someone in the 1400s in the you know in
the - in 1200 AD would you have said the
same if someone was coming in
essentially freeing these peasants from
this life that they had and gifting them
wealth that they would never ever be
able to access themselves like well
maybe it's a little bit more again I
just have no I have no way to frame that
I mean I think it's it's um it's really
so if we if we stick with that kind of
if we view it as a sort of different
type son you know eight hundred years
prior or something something akin to
that kind of era you you sort of move
past I guess you kind of it becomes
easier to sort of move past judgment you
know if you take your ancestors I should
imagine 800 years ago your ancestors
probably did some really unpleasant
things but they did what they had to do
to survive they did what they were
taught to do they did I guess what they
thought was appropriate given the
context that they were faced with and I
think that it's really easy to judge
people with a historical perspective you
often get this in the States at the
moment you know where the sort of
founding fathers maybe had some
different views on slavery you know and
people are like oh this is really bad
you got owned slaves and exactly yeah
yeah we could have we've got to raise
them for history and I'm like well hang
on a sec if if the subsequent
generations judge the past and the
behavior of the people that came before
them it's a really easy question to sort
of judge them and go where you know that
was disgraceful my challenge is to what
what are your grandchildren what are
your great-grandchildren gonna judge you
for you know 100 years time when you're
you know if you live to that age you sat
there with your grandchild and that turn
around go I can't leave it used to do
that what are they going to be talking
about and I have no idea really I think
this is a more interesting question I
think a very good suggestion for what
that might be is factory farming there's
a lot very clever people that I know who
think that in a couple of hundred years
or more let's say that we're able to
create a cost-effective grown petri dish
meat which allows people to hit that
particular caloric requirement but
without having to create animals
literally to be slaughtered I think that
that world would look back on us and
think hang on you did you you threw away
50 percent of every chicken all of the
chicken breeds that you made literally
just into a meat grinder I'm not a
vegetarian or a vegan woman spend time
around some ones that are terrifyingly
clever and I'm kind of drinking the
kool-aid at least a little bit from them
but yeah like you did what you just they
were born and then taken away from them
so that the mum would give milk so that
you could drink the milk as opposed to
you know that that to me I think is one
of those and you're right the beauty of
hindsight is that it's 20/20 vision any
hyung is amazing perspective where
you're able to see well this is framed
within the values of now and it's I kiss
but it wasn't now it was then and now is
now and in the future it won't be now
either yeah and that's the thing I know
I get that's one of the sort of I guess
my concerns about the modern world is
that it's so easy to take someone out
context it's so easy to make a sort of
snap judgment on someone that maybe says
something and is kind of thinking out
loud and people are so quick to jump all
over that stuff and it could be really
really damaging to people's careers and
reputations and I think it shuts down
debate which I don't think is helpful no
lenten especially with the frictionless
communication which we've got you know
like if if Kevin Hart can get borderline
canceled the hardest-working one
the best the best paid comedian on the
planet if we can get water line
cancelled for a tweet that was a decade
ago like yeah none of us are safe
apologize for countlessly which you like
no what do what do you think the store
manager Asda or you know the guy in the
military you know what do you think the
the Marines officer now Oh like he's on
Facebook since he was 10 or 12 or
whatever you're allowed to get it or
something like that like it's so I'm
just I'm glad that I didn't have social
media until I was at least borderline an
adult because I would have been
I'd have been making mistakes all over
the place and you're right like the
reason for communication is that you are
allowed to play with ideas if that's
what you like to do and I'm one of the
people that does like to do that you're
supposed to be able to play with ideas
what are the back I'm not supposed to
have to make sure that I'm saying it in
a nerfed environment where it won't get
leaked out beyond the boundaries of
people who actually know what I'm
talking about I know that I'm not a
bigoted racist homophobe transphobes
enol mean like list off whatever it is
that someone's going to accuse you of
doing because you wanted to work try and
say something that was not even half
formed in your mind that can then get
taken out of context and obviously the
people that are that are in these
positions of public renown there's even
the stakes are even higher for them yeah
no I completely agree I mean I think
people people assume that just because
you say something it's a kind of clearly
articulated you know carefully window
into your soul thought and it's just not
I mean I've got script in front of me
you through whew yeah we're having a
conversation so I don't really know
what's gonna come out next and this risk
big that's part of it and yeah you're
very right so I want to I want to find
out about the fact that you were a
pirate hunter tell us about and tell us
about being a pirate hunter so piracy
was really interesting actually I did my
first tour off the coast of Somalia in
late 2010 and I was the
intelligent office intelligence officer
so what my job really involved there was
effectively looking at aerial
photographs of camps and trying to get
my head inside the sort of mind of a
pirate and Percy's interestings it's not
the same as it's not the same as an
Islamic fundamentalism fundamentally
this is a business model for them in
moment they feel that they cannot the
the risk outweighs the reward they'll
sort of pull back and they won't go
anymore so I went off to so I went off
the coast of Somalia late 2010 and then
again late 2011 and the reason it was
sort of September to December was
because as the monsoon changes as it
moves from Southeast to Northwest or or
the other way around you get a period of
sort of very calm water in the Indian
Ocean and when the waters calmed small
boats can get a reasonable speed up and
they can effectively hunt down merchant
shipping when the sea states really
choppy it's like driving fast on a very
bumpy road
you trash the boats you can't get up to
the sort of full speed where is the big
stuff because it frankly doesn't really
have any impact on that they can just
charge straight through it and basically
outrun the small boats so again a couple
of turns off the coast they're arresting
and interdicting pirates who claim that
they were fishermen despite the fact
that we've sort of have a helicopter
over the side over the top as they were
chucking weapons and ladders over the
side and those sort of a complete
absence of fishing gear again really a
really interesting term that both of
them were that sort of really changed my
perspective one of my guys we arrested
some pirates or one of my guys said look
we've got a guy here who's been shot and
I was like patty Martin you know no no
no this happened obviously quite a while
ago and basically you can sort of see my
forearm there what this guy had was I'd
say probably about a 10 10 degree angle
in his forearm and one forearm was about
that much longer than the other and I
looked at this and I looked at it so a
wrist and he'd clearly you know he'd
been shot in the wrist
he'd had a really catastrophic injury
and it had never been splinted correctly
it had just been sort of wrapped up he'd
till he had some antibiotics pumped into
him and he'd survived it and I remember
saying to my Marines I you know like
guys you you can you [ __ ] and moan when
there isn't you know a second dessert on
the ship this guy has been shot in the
wrist he's clearly survived it and now
he's got this at a pone of injury and
again you sort of realized that huge
amounts of the world are totally
uncovered and the people with the
biggest stick or the most weapons
they're the ones that rule the roost and
while we might [ __ ] and moan about the
state of this country actually go and
wander around Somalia you know go to
sort of some Far East parts of you know
Ethiopia or you know other parts of the
world that are less developed see how
they live and then ask yourself how well
you've got it but there's I think most
of the time you find actually again
coming back to this sort of accident of
history thing you know if your family's
lives are on the line your values change
very very quickly around what you are
willing to do and what you're not
willing to do and again yeah another
another great experience yeah off the
coast of Somalia was lucky enough to
recapture a pirated vessel as well which
was yeah which was a good experience
well I want to hear about that in a
second but sure one of the one of the
things that's coming to mind is I wonder
what would happen if nuclear war broke
out tomorrow or there was some sort of
catastrophe that meant it was pretty
much every family for themselves and I
wonder how many of the people who have
civility and and tolerance and all the
rest of it as their front line of
personality and how they identify I
wonder how long that would stay if it
was dog eat dog it would be very
interesting to find out I mean the
number of people that said to me you
know I I would never be able to kill
someone and you're just like well I'll
give you a situation you come home
someone's got a knife to one of your
children's you know necks you have an
opportunity to take a shot at very short
range
would you do it yeah right so the
context is the context has changed your
view on that of course you would you
know given the right situation people
are capable of from some fairly
unpleasant and violent things and I
think you know if you you probably sort
of you know he looked into the sort of
studies around evil the sort of various
experiments that have been done context
and the way the environment shapes our
behavior is hugely powerful I can't
remember the name of that experiment
where it was done in the US where the
people were sort of shocking each other
or shocking an actor you know there was
that in the Prison Experiment the
Stanford Prison Experiment that got out
of control all these are normal people
within a relatively short space of time
capable of doing some really unpleasant
things to others so I'd be very careful
when people say that they're unable to
do those kind of things I think given
the context and the situation they're
presented with I think we're all capable
of violence if we have to be the thing
is well that you keep alluding to is
that the only reason that you or me or
anyone that's listening isn't that girl
with her jaw hanging off or her mother
or father is purely by roll of the dice
your consciousness could have been that
one could have been a different one
could have been whatever one and the
fact that you happened to be born in one
of the best countries in the world in
the best time in history with yet the
most wellness and the longest lifespan
and the best economic opportunities and
continue to roll it out from there you
know and I I do the same I catch myself
all the time complaining about I can't
believe that my dopamine receptors are
being manipulated by Facebook and then
go what you're talking about you've got
this Oracle in your pocket which has
access to all of human history's wisdom
like he one thing one counter-argument
to myself now and I brought this up on a
previous podcast was
I agreed that we need to have
perspective when we make judgments about
the world that we live in right we need
to think like it could be so much worse
you could be being attacked by Somali
pirates you could have half of your job
being blown off for you know a couple of
hundred dollars or whatever it might be
but on the flip side the only
alternative to that is well I'm just
going to go through saying that this is
good enough as our standard of living
increases and as the resolution and the
fidelity with which we look at the state
of society and technology and how we are
all combining ourselves together as that
improves we have to look at it with an
increasingly sharp eye glass because
otherwise if it's not point looking at
today by the standards of 50 years ago
because it's not useful
it hasn't me okay so where are the
failings that we have right now based on
the qualities and the opportunities and
the technologies and everything else the
understandings that we have how can we
improve this right now not by the
standards of Afghanistan not by the
standards of the Somali pirates but
where you are when you are hmm no I
completely agree with that but I think
you're right with your starting point
which has to be a sense of you know what
it's pretty good it's all pretty good
right now that doesn't mean we don't
have issues or doesn't mean we don't
have problems but by and large and you
just have to look at the data you know
any any data you know if you look at
sort of infant mortality literacy
violence against women and girls all of
that is getting a hell of a lot better
so ripping apart the system and throwing
out the baby with the bathwater I don't
agree I think actually it is about sort
of incremental steady change you know we
have a welfare state in this a welfare
system in this country that's a good
thing I don't think that many people
take advantage of it others might
disagree with me but by and large I
think it is a it's a great thing that we
have that and that we're able to pay for
that as that hasn't previously existed
yeah it's a relatively recent invention
wasn't it the I think the UN had the
a target of having world poverty within
I think it was 40 years and they did it
within that 25 or something and the
change in poverty across the world
people that were living below that
particular which I think's actually only
about four thousand thinks about four
thousand dollars a year is yeah is it
around about the the barrier for that
and if they hate within essentially half
the time or like two-thirds of the time
yeah I mean it is it's astonishing
actually kind of how good things are you
know the murder rate for example another
one massively down on where it used to
be how do you what I was trying to do
with my second analogy there was how do
we hold to two things in mind at the
same time the first one being we are
living in the best time that there ever
has been in one of the best countries
that there is to live in whilst we can
be better how do we hold those two
things in our mind at the same time I
mean I don't think that mutually
exclusive I think you can be grateful
for what you've got but harness that
thirst and that ambition to improve the
status quo I mean I'm really thankful
for everything I've got you know two
healthy children you know a wife that
loves me and a business that is that
frankly like his work that I love doing
and I'm enjoying it well I I'm you know
I'm a nine on the scale of you know
gratitude really I've got nothing
nothing that I'm not you know largely
happy about but that doesn't mean that I
feel I've achieved everything I want to
I still have a sort of really strong
drive and a desire to I guess improve
the situation for other people or
improve the status quo I get
uncomfortable I get uncomfortable when
people give me really nicely
you know refined you know answers to the
way things are because
I just don't think the world works like
that I think everything is kind of a
work in progress and I can't kind of
happy with that I think you can hold
those two things I think you can I think
you can love for example I think you can
love your children for the person that
they are but I think you can have high
expectations of them and you can hold
them to account I don't think there's
anything wrong with that
so I don't see them as mutually
exclusive I think that they are I think
that you can hold those two two things
in your mind it comes back to nuances
well that isn't it what we were talking
about before you've got to be able to
have that subtlety in your conversation
and to be allowed to play with ideas
because it's not you know we're trying
to work something out here you know you
get better than anyone else on the
planet and even you are still thinking
okay so how can I even just express
briefly what I mean when I say that I
like my children I love them for who
they are but I want them to be better
you know even if that's all that you're
grappling with is to try and
linguistically make it make sense how do
you then deploy you know it's difficult
it's hot these things are challenging
and I think it's a there's a lot of
laziness that comes from people who want
to be able to just put a single tweet
length
it's like conclusion to whatever it is
or you know back from that even more and
just a label like a single word yeah
that's what the trouble that's one of
the problems is that I think you know
everyone wants the executive summary you
know I don't want to know the working
out I don't know what how you got to the
answer I want the executive summary
I want the Twitter answer and it's like
yeah but there's there's no depth
there's no understanding there there's
no ability to adjust a way of looking at
things depending on that context the
world is a really really complicated
place and I think just reminding
ourselves that the rule that we're all
just grappling with trying to understand
it a little bit better trying to
understand ourselves and other people I
yeah I think being comfortable with that
being being comfortable with uncertainty
is a kind of key skill in the Monde
world taking that across to the Armed
Forces in the way that that works
obviously the whole
reason that you have a line of command
within the armed forces and operating
procedures is to try and simplify that
decision-making process is to try and
have some guidelines for how you bring
order to chaos right mm-hmm how is there
a mindset change that happens when
people join you know let's say that
someone comes in and someone has this
particular worldview which is very very
complex and then they need to kind of
they're just right okay forget all of
the gesticulating forget the is it right
is it wrong it just needs to be you
follow the orders is do you watch people
change sort of when they join in the
potentially go from one type of person
to another I think there were certain so
that the military is far less command
and control that people think it is okay
so a lot of the time you get this view
that it's all about you know you are
told what to do yes sir exactly yes
no sir all of that kind of thing the
kind of you know full-metal-jacket drill
sergeant a raising your personality and
whilst there is an element of that
that's required fundamentally all of
those lessons in the early days are
really can you follow simple
instructions and can you meet our
standards now if you look at any form of
operational excellence the first step in
operational excellence is to standardize
the process that's all the military is
doing so can you iron your shirt can you
polish your boots can you pack your kit
can you do things to a certain level
right okay you can right the next step
is to now move on to weapons can you
keep your weapon system clean can you
handle it responsibly all of these kind
of things they're just building blocks
in order to get you to understand how to
use this equipment safely but then you
get to this stage where you're put into
a position of responsibility or
authority and things are chaotic and you
need to make decisions and what the
military are very good at is is giving
people an end state so if you were
working for me
I'd say look Chris this is this is what
I want you to achieve this is the end
state that I set you this is the future
that I want you to get to how you
achieve that totally up to you come back
to me if you need support or extra
resource the how is up to you now
because we leave for how up to you as an
individual that makes you unpredictable
and being unpredictable in combat is
really really important because the
moment you become predictable people can
effectively ambush you because they know
what you're going to do next
and that's how it's done it's all done
around a sort of common language of
intent what is my commanding officer
well it's his intent what does he want
to happen and then how do I use the
resources I've got in order to achieve
that in my own way but it's not
prescriptive and in any way I'm left to
kind of work it with that yeah that's
interesting I've been thinking a lot
recently about the the elements that we
all need to help us perform a little bit
better and I think for so many people
its direction and accountability you
need to know yeah where you are going
and don't need to be accountable to
someone if you don't go in that
direction and it's interesting that you
have identified in the way that the
military is pieced together that that
that really is two of the key elements a
hundred percent and I the accountability
thing you know when people say what's
the one thing you miss about the
organisation it's like it is a hundred
percent the accountability people I
never felt that I had to give an order I
think if you have to rely on your rank
in the military you failed somewhere
along the line to build trust to build
that relationship but like if I asked
one of my corporals and my sergeants to
do something it was absolutely gonna
happen I could set my watch by it
because they would work through the
night to make sure it did happen they
wouldn't clock off at 5:00 and go I
can't get that done mm-hmm there was a
just a different sense of ownership they
took responsibility and they delivered
to that end state and you know if it was
something really simple like you know I
needed to book a hire car to go and have
a look at a range you know someone would
say to me okay so
whereas you're going oh I'm going up to
this place in you know castlemartin on
the edge of Wales okay so what I'll do
is I'll book a hire car and I get it to
come to your house the night before so
you can leave early I'll make sure
there's one of those this is back in the
day when there's a tag to go across the
bridge I'll make sure there's one of
those in there and I'll get you a
slightly bigger one so it's more
comfortable journey it's like like
hundred percent so much more accountable
you know by seeking an understanding of
right what is it you're trying to
achieve you're trying to do something
relatively simple there okay so how can
I best help you to achieve that effect
is that partly due to the common purpose
I think it's more to do with the common
understanding of you're like me you're
you're one of us you know you wear row
Marines commando you know on the side of
your shirt you wear the green beret I'm
here to help you be successful and vice
versa and I mean it's unbelievable what
can be achieved when when people have
that mindset when they genuinely believe
that the fundamental priority is to
support the success of others
it's very customer focused to use some
corporate speak if I can vary customer
focus is is part of that the shared
experience of going through the
preparation to get to where you are the
fact that you all have that commonality
I think so I think generally speaking
the people that don't look out for
others the people that don't adhere to
the values you know of the raw Marines
they don't survive they get they get
found out and fundamentally the group
makes it uncomfortable for them to sort
of stick around and be there so you know
you can't be you will find it's
certainly very difficult and training if
you're one of those people that you know
at the end of an exercise disappears off
to clean your personal weapon rather
than helping other guys get around some
of the heavier machinery to clean that
people will find you out and people will
say something it comes back to that
accountability point of view people will
say you know I know that you think
you're you're pretty awesome but I see
you you're a selfish bloke I
and I'm gonna I'm gonna hold you to
account for that I'm gonna say that your
face the pressure ultimately creates
that environment where you just don't
have time for people that don't pull
their weight the stakes are much higher
as well you know it's not it's not just
put that person that same person who
might be the guy that calls out the
person who doesn't go and clean the big
gun in 20 years later in corporate world
might actually let it slide once inside
you know what it is it's not [ __ ]
life or death but it actually is life or
death is like the stakes are a lot
higher it's it's a shame that we can't
port that the stakes across to the
corporate world it's it's difficult I'm
not saying it's impossible but it's very
hard because people have no context of
what it's like to work in environment
where the team does become the team
comes before your needs you know that's
a really difficult thing to get your
head round around putting the needs of
the group above yourself but once you're
in that environment it's the closest
you'll get to blood relatives and family
you know the word Brotherhood is often
used to describe the relationships
relationships between men in combat and
it's a hundred percent true so so yeah I
think I think it's difficult to
experience that and therefore it's
difficult to recreate it right let's get
back to Somali I wanna I want to find
out about the Pirates so first off why
why is Somalia a hotbed for it was there
just that some guy that was there that
said this this seems like a good
business opportunity were in the right
location or some fellow just started
selling boats and ak-47s so no I think
it's I think it's a combination of a
couple of things one huge numbers of
ships go from the southern coast of
India up through past Yemen past Somalia
and up through the Suez Canal I don't
know what the statistics are but some
enormous percentage of trade goes
through that that route so there's a lot
of ships going that way secondly Somalia
again
it's unhelpful to think of it as a
country it's largely uncovered space yes
it is a country on a map but outside of
Mogadishu the Somali government doesn't
have a huge amount of control and you've
got these sort of various autonomous
region so around Mogadishu is largely
sort of quite chaotic al-shabaab Isis
Islamic fundamentalists north of that
you've got Puntland which is slightly
more slightly more governed but I
certainly wouldn't be looking to go
there on holiday but then you know in
Somaliland to the very north I mean you
could fly there for London and you could
if you wanted to go on holiday though
and you'd probably be quite safe so it's
that kind of uncovered space access to
to weapons and and fundamentally yeah
you know it's an opportunity it is an
opportunity that people have decided
yeah we're going to go we're going to go
after this the fact that you said it was
a it's a business these people see it as
a commercial enterprise was there's
really sort of I don't know why I don't
know why I thought that it would be
because of something else some sort of
distaste for the ships that were going
by or something like that it's just a
opportunity to make profit it's a
business model and I think you know the
you know what if you again come back to
the sort of ratios and the numbers you
know ten thousand dollars to them is
more than they can expect to earn in
their entire lifetimes so yeah again I
haven't done the numbers but call it a
couple of million quid what would what
would solve the criminals in our country
do or what would some people do for a
couple of million pounds probably again
it kind of changes the sort of risk
reward
criteria for people for them you know
again it's life and death it is
literally it can be as simple as that
you know there isn't there is almost no
other way to provide for their families
so they used to go and do this which
again is why I I won't judge them
because if I was born on that side of
the world would I be comfortable to pick
up a rifle go and find my family well I
did it here so probably
do you think that other some of the
pirates that you encountered that did it
with glee I don't I don't think so
certainly not with us they were fairly
contrite I mean the big core but they
think or even when we'd fly the
helicopter pass they had a sort of
understanding of our rules of engagement
you know they would hold up
you know rocket-propelled grenade
launchers in a very kind of I've got
this so [ __ ] off otherwise because you
know if they turn it and face it at us
that's a threat to life we can engage
them but we can shoot them with snipers
they were switched on to that kind of
thing so they knew our rules of
engagement as well yeah I mean a lot
like you know primitive yes but capable
definitely what's there what's there ml
done talk me through how they go about
trying to take down a ship what they'll
do is you'll have maybe two probably too
small skiffs now a skiff is 20 to 30
feet long speedboat with a pretty heavy
motor on the back of it as in something
with probably 50 plus horsepower
something that can get up to 30 knots
relatively quickly that's one of the
ways in which you can identify them
because of course why would a fisherman
require an expensive high-end engine
they don't so the way they'll do it is
that they will they will shadow the
vessel one on the port side one on the
starboard side and what they're looking
to do is is trying to get the vessel to
turn one way or the other because if the
vessels going into the prevailing
weather if it turns one way it kind of
creates a it creates almost a calm area
to one side and what they'll do is
they'll come up alongside
if there are no if there's no barbed
wire I mean it's literally a question of
putting a ladder up and climbing on
board they've Hastings are like some
Lord of the Rings thing like just yeah
not to some
to that yeah yeah exactly that like it's
it's a ladder straight over the side and
then straight up so what they're looking
for is is a vessel with a low free board
so a deck that's very close to the water
so that that that is easy to do and
they're looking for something without
sort of any kind of countermeasures if
there are other things like barbed wire
running around the outside of the ship
I've not seen it but I have heard what
they'll do is they'll take a grappling
hook
chuck it onto the barbed wire attach the
grappling hook to a bucket put the
bucket in the water and then the barbed
wire gets pulled back as the ship tries
to drag the bucket now again like that's
incredibly simple very very innovative
but all that does is create enough of a
gap for them to get up underneath and
these guys are obviously pretty thin and
they're only carrying a rifle once
they're on board they're going for
they're going for the bridge the bridge
is the control center of the ship
they're going to try and get in there
and they are going to ultimately use
violence and aggression to sort of take
the thing over there then take it into
Somali territorial waters they stick it
in an anchorage they contact the ship
owner and they start Ram something and
that's basically how it works
the only real way or the way in which
you combat it is really with guys on
onboard with guns they won't again this
is a business model they're not fanatics
so they will they won't they won't go
after ships that have people on board
with weapons who are protecting them and
particularly sort of high freeboard
there's a cold kind of risk criteria
that you know that you can sort of look
at I mean once the ships alongside you
know those crew and pretty pretty dire
straits because now they're looking at
we're not talking weeks here we normally
talking months of negotiations to get
the price down and then the sort of the
payment of the ransom and that's
generally what's done I think is largely
and money drop in cash and that's it
they got off take that money with them
go back to shore
ship goes on it's play
so what tell us about the particular
incident that you had where you
recapture the vessels so the ship in
question was a vessel called the MV
Montecristo is a fifty five fifty five
thousand ton container ship so pretty
big container ship had pirates on board
and an unarmed security team and what
this unarmed security team did was
effectively get everyone into the engine
room lock it down
you can you can control the ship from
the engine room largely so that was kind
of the sort of the thing to do look
everyone in there and then and just sort
of keep everyone safe now if the crew
are isolated from the pirates it's
actually a relatively simple boarding
because you don't have hostages
mixed in with pirates shoot anyone that
isn't in the engine room
fundamentally you can get onboard and if
it goes a bit kinetic and round start
going down you haven't got that added
risk so there are various or the
categories of a boarding and a level
four is a hostage rescue which is part
you know pirates are on board there in
amongst the crew that is a very
difficult situation to to sort of deal
with us you know remit of Special Forces
we used to be able to deal with the
level three which is the crew are locked
in the safe room there are no other crew
it's only pirates on board we would go
on with the sort of black roll kit you
know fully black overalls you know dark
sunglasses helmets body armor matter and
say but yes it was it was the best job I
had it was just brilliant did you listen
to ac/dc pumping out the speakers on the
way I feel I've missed something there I
feel that yeah this is missing some of
that would it be would be pretty special
Brian Giles and pounding down on the
these Somali pirates and thinking [ __ ]
Brian's here
I mean they were because of the like
because I mean Marines are fairly big
physical physical guys covered in this
kit with all this body armor the guys
look physically imposing and there was a
there was a logic to that because it's a
little bit of sort of almost like you
know dog psychology you know if a guy if
you come across a guy who's sort of six
foot five and and built like a brick
[ __ ] in a pub you're unlikely to
stop him if something goes down so it's
that same sort of thing you want to
appear physically imposing we were
respectful but very very firm you know
we would grip them we would control them
we would put plastic halves on them as
quickly as possible they were not we
never we never hurt any of them but we
were we were sort of firm as he'd expect
a police officer in the UK to be dealing
with someone that's potentially
dangerous it's firm it's not it's not
aggressive you're not trying to hurt
them so so yeah we we recaptured the
vessel release the crew
I remember going down into the engine
room and it was probably the only time
in my career that was a real tangible
sense of we've delivered some real value
for people because they were overwhelmed
with emotion they were crying they were
cheering you didn't get that in
Afghanistan very often ever there was
this sort of overwhelming sense of you
know gratitude and thanks
we then because it was an Italian
flagged vessels the Italian government
wanted to prosecute them I think one of
the first successful prosecutions for
piracy and God knows how many years they
got carted off to they got carted off to
Rome I went there and acted as a witness
of the for the prosecution which was
fascinating going into sort of one of
these mafia style you know courtrooms
with all the sort of you know rooms
alongside where they could put all this
sort of you know large numbers of mob
bosses and I'm there this is sort of few
pirates in there
what I noticed interesting again comes
back to
you don't be aware of your incentives
all of them have put on weight sighs I
hang on a sec we're gonna we're gonna
send them to prison in Italy and that's
probably a better outcome foot yeah the
big gonna eat that a nicer climate more
humid right you know don't get me wrong
I'm like I'm totally comfortable and all
fine with that but I'm like how's this a
disincentive to that kind of behavior
when you know CAPTCHA ends up in this so
yeah get the boat couple of million quid
don't get them all like holiday or Rome
yeah Prison prison in Rome do you know
how much room three meals are don't you
know how much time they got I think it
was sort of between 15 and 18 years sort
of in the sort of serious in that so
yeah I mean it was yeah they're not
messing about but then I don't know what
happens I don't know what happens after
that
so do they get sent back you know that
creates kind of another question and
this is part of the issues that you know
that the you know the government NATO
euro you know Europe we sort of want to
do something about that but we're not
kind of totally sure on how to solve
that problem
ultimately it's been solved by the
market for private security I believe
you know enough guys on ships with guns
sooner ladies guys basically like look
we can't get on to anything and I think
it's much quieter than well it certainly
is much quieter just the number of
attacks the number of pirated ships I'm
a little bit out of the loop with all
that stuff now but but certainly as much
question there has been before
was it a bit of a golden era or a hot at
least a hot era when sort of 2010 ish in
before man yeah completely it was yeah
the number of the number of pirating the
number of attacks was escalating rapidly
this was something that people didn't
really know you know how to have to deal
with it
you know the carriage of weapons its
life at sea is a lot of kind of gray
areas so you know let's say you bought
you bought some security guys in India
with some rifles and they get off in
Djibouti which is the kind of high-risk
like are there any implications around
gun running then because they're getting
on with rifles again say becomes all and
I know that there have been people have
been really sort of caught out with this
I believe actually rather unfortunately
there are still some British servicemen
serving time in Mumbai when it all of
that kind of stuff went sort of South
very quickly and and again it's you know
it's it's uncovered space you can't go
out to those kind of places and sort of
handle weapons and assume that it's kind
of all okay because it's again it's a
it's a dangerous and a and a deeply you
know complex and nuanced world out there
no really know what's going on in those
places so I was never tempted by the
maritime security law right yeah it just
strikes me how different some areas of
the world are another son stupid like
obviously obviously a lot of areas of
the world are different but when you say
like that when you say that you know
these the values that some people are
living by and essentially the time that
some civilizations are living in some
some areas of the world are living in is
so drastically different from ours
completely and you know again it's it's
it's just that's I'd hugely value travel
a hugely value any kind of experience
that takes you out of the ones that you
are familiar with because you can it
will change the way you think and see
the world it'll change the way you
interact with people it'll change it'll
change everything that everything about
how you how you think about human
behavior and that's a massively valuable
lesson so you finished
catching pirates and decided that you
were going to go into the world of
business and leadership yes I I I got
some really good advice when I left
which was you know don't don't go and do
something similar to what you've done
before you know really push yourself and
go to a sort of different environments
so I went into uranium enrichment for a
couple of years I worked for a company
Remco based up in Cheshire really
interesting environment you know I did a
degree in ancient history so I'm going
to work in the nuclear industry you know
no real concept of that very
safety-critical culture the words
nuclear and accident don't go well
together and it's unacceptable to take
any form of sort of personal risk in
order to get the job done whereas you
know my health and safety was a helmet
and body armor and plenty of ammunition
going into that world that required a
complete mindset change for me but what
I fundamentally realized was that you
know it doesn't matter whether you're
leading a team of Marines leading a
sports team leading a business or
leading a group of uranium-enrichment
technicians ultimately team performance
is dependent on leadership culture
behaviour the context really I think
people overstate the value of having had
to work in the industry that they're in
it's relatively easy to understand that
I think it's more under more important
to be able to sort of understand people
so I sort of became interested in in
effectively in leadership in taking the
skills that I learned in the military
and sort of coaching leaders and helping
them to sort of improve the performance
of their people because fundamentally
that's what I enjoyed most about being
in the Marines helping others to get
better I've got a real sort of kick out
of that so if you could take some of the
values that were common in the Armed
Forces and import them into the business
world or some of the elements what would
be some of the things that you would
take across would you have iron shirts
and shiny shoes Oh take standards
I wouldn't necessarily have the the
dress code yeah but the stats down it's
a really interesting one because I think
you know what you what you're willing to
accept in terms of standards of
performance standards of behavior is
really important because that sort of
sets the tone for your organization
I've already talked about the
accountability I lutely take that that
would be invaluable in any organization
because you'd be
to just get so much more done I think
the key thing that I would take is the
sort of leadership view that you are
there to improve the performance of your
people I think so often in organizations
people get promoted to a leadership
position because they're good at doing
stuff and what that does is it
reinforces the mindset of the doer and
actually what I try and work with people
to change is that you're it's not about
you doing things now it's about that
group over there it's about spending
time improving the performance of the
team you have been promoted because
you're good at playing the instrument
but now you've got to conduct the
orchestra so stop playing the instrument
it's a totally different way of thinking
and I think organizations generally
don't do a very good job of it they sort
of promote people and then kind of
expect them sort of get on with it and
that's the sort of problem or that's the
issue that I hope to address in some
small way really because if I work with
someone relatively early in their career
and I make them like 5% better at
leading people that has an impact not
just on their current team but all the
people that they work with for the rest
of their life and that is in some small
way going to contribute towards making
the world a better place and that's why
I do it I think you're right I recently
spoke to Benjamin Dennehy who is the
UK's most hated sales trainer and he was
talking about when he goes into sales
companies and a lot of the time they
will have a good salesman really they
know top performer they think rites time
to move this person up they give him a
promotion they make him a team leader
and their lives a good salesman and gain
a ship manager yeah and yeah it's that
going from doer to enabler yeah I see
that sales classic absolutely classic
and the organization often people here
sometimes people have said to me you
know what I was much happier when I was
just doing the selling and I'm like
that's that's okay you need to I think
not everyone management isn't right for
everyone
leadership isn't necessarily right for
everyone I think you kind of have to ask
the individual look
do you want to just do you want to pay
rise would you on the team yeah okay
you can negotiate yourself out and just
say look I just think I want more money
but I'm the best seller on the floor the
best seller on the team the best
whatever like yeah and there is there's
a because we are our jobs now so much
there is this desire for natural
progression this sense that if you're
not moving up within the organization
but unfortunately I think a lot of the
skills that make someone a good member
of staff don't necessarily translate up
to being a good manager but one of the
difficulties that I see and a lot of the
listeners might be able to see this
within their own organizations as well
is that respect tends to be emergent not
dictated within an organization so if
you just import some manager who's never
worked in [ __ ] uranium before and
he's got some classical history degree
and was just shooting pirates a couple
years ago like why should I listen to
this Schmo like talking about you know
he doesn't he's not been at the coalface
he's not you know earned his keep he's
not done this that on the other and you
that the problems that a good leader and
a good manager within an organization
has to get past like these sort of
invisible hurdles or steps that you need
to climb it's like you need to be able
to get the respect of people sometimes
without having earned it by coming up
through the system then you need to
actually have good leadership skills
then you have to be able to get them to
listen to you then Direction
accountability to did it like it's
challenging I didn't it doesn't surprise
me that we have dysfunction within
organizations yeah and I think it's it's
it's a real shame it's a real waste of
potential potential for those
individuals in those jobs potential for
those people in those leadership
positions you know most people and I've
got sort of statistics to hand but you
know that's well known that most people
don't like what they do for a living you
know eighty-five percent of people are
either nonplussed or actively disengaged
with their job it's only 15 percent of
people this is us data
15% of people who are actively engaged
with the profession that they have I
mean [ __ ] that's a waste of potential
like you know that is that is a real
waste and there's no other word for it
you know I think I think one of the
things that you know I I've realized
about myself as I I don't like
inefficiency I don't like waste I was
really startled by your you know your
observation of you know you hang on us
that you take fifty percent of what you
saw like the chicken did you just chuck
away the rest you know I think of you
I'm like [ __ ] that's awful you know it
drives me mad
because that's something that could
benefit someone else so it's just that
that inefficiency is a real shame and I
think that's kind of one of the reasons
I sort of went out on my own decided to
sort of start this was because there's
so much of it and it's so often you know
the solution is offered by someone that
believes that leadership can be
summarized in three you know acronyms
you know it's about being you know
responsible or courageous and
accountable and I'm just like no because
if you're telling me it's all about
empowerment I will find a context of
where it doesn't work so for example if
you would say to me look rod leadership
is fundamentally all about empowerment
I'd say yeah ninety percent of the time
I agree with you that's true but if you
and me were crossing the road together
and we saw someone in front of us get
hit by a car and had their legs taken
off the last thing you want me to do is
turn around and go because you wanna
call an ambulance now do you think
that's the right thing to do it's
totally inappropriate right it's a
totally inappropriate way of behaving
and I think that yes fundamentally
that's what that's what leadership is
it's all about behavior you don't get to
decide whether you're a good leader or
not other people do that's one of the
paradoxes of it and it requires good
judgment it requires you know a clear
sense of who you are what you're good at
what you're not good at it's a very
broad subject tonight you know I don't
pretend to don't pretend to be an expert
you know I hate it when people say oh
you're elite I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
learning more about it but if I if I
humor I'm an expert if I assume I'm in
Lee in anything like that it creates the
conditions for complacency and I don't
want to do that you'll have that
learners mind I think with things like
this and it would appear that you're
importing some effective strategies
right some you know structures and
processes from your past life life lives
that are that are really going to be
beneficial but on the flip side of that
like again nuance subtlety individual
situations that we come up against all
that sort of stuff you said earlier on
about how when you were in the Armed
Forces you would never have to kind of
like pull rank on someone or use your
title it's like because I'm your
commanding officer like if you have to
say that because I'm your commanding
officer line it's I get you've kind of
lost but how many times do you have this
almost parent and child situation that
I've seen in within organizations and
businesses and even been a part of it
myself right it's like make because I'm
telling you to like and I don't want to
have to pull that pin I don't want to
have to use the that line but you know
ineffective leadership misaligned values
someone being in a position that they
don't want and for anyone who's
listening you know might be in a
managerial position and thinking my [ __ ]
you know well I've got to I've got to
pull that pin all the time I need to you
know like crank the handle really hard
on all of my staff to get them to go you
know from a compassionate side we've
just given you the statistic that 85% of
people are either essentially nonplussed
or actively disengaged with their jobs
85% of the people that you are trying to
manage potentially 100% because I don't
know how that skews that yeah top 90 at
the top 15 might actually be all people
in like top end positions or whatever um
all the people that you're speaking to a
big majority of them don't give a [ __ ]
but they actually actually genuinely do
not give a [ __ ] about what it is that
you're telling them and you're trying to
get into work every single day and try
and make this more efficient and it must
be a terrible manager I must really be a
really bad leader I just can't get the
team to listen to me I can't get them to
buy into what I'm doing
you know try and give them the processes
and give them the structures and give
them the support and then it just so
nothing back yeah it's it's
astonishingly common and it's again it's
really sad I mean you ask people like
you ask people missing you know how well
do you know your people how well do you
know your team yeah I know reasonably
were by okay
do you know where they were born you
know where they grew up you know what
school they went to you know where they
went to university what are they study
what do they do on their weekends what
do they do with this to expose a link up
have they got children what are their
names how old are they no right but then
you don't know your people and if you
don't know them you can't pull those
levers in order to manage them and sort
of stoke the fires of their ambition or
their drive but equally if you don't
know them the unwritten message or the
underlying message is that you don't
give a [ __ ] about them that's what they
think that's what they feel now they may
never ever tell you that but that's the
reality of it so you know it's a really
easy you know talk about practical
takeaways you know sit down with your
team and say look I just want to get to
know you so this might sound a bit
invasive don't ask don't answer anything
you're not comfortable with but you know
those kind of questions and if you say
that your team is too big because you've
got eight or ten people I did it with 30
people every single time because if you
don't do that the unwritten message is
you don't give a [ __ ] about them and it
would be really important like you know
speaking to marine do you want to be the
next regimental sergeant major or do you
want to do four years get a skill get
trade and then punch out the answers
fine either one is fine but help me so
that I can help you in managing your
career and using work that comes across
my desk to help you move in that
direction so it's a really simple
example we'd have to do troop circuits I
want to be a PTI that's what I want to
be in the Rory's
you're going to start running a couple
of circuits a week and I'm gonna give
you feedback on them and then at the end
of the year I can write you up and say
you understand the principles of
exercise you've added some really
inventive stuff to this hasn't just been
the sort of you know usual kind of
circuit they've been fun they've been
interact
I can set you off on that course that's
I can't do that unless I know what that
individual wants to do so I'm really
surprised at when people don't know that
stuff it's interesting that friendships
are often built around vulnerability I
tend to say that the best friendships
that you have are the ones where you or
the other person can tell each other
something that in the wrong hands would
be catastrophic to the way that other
people see that you bond around
something which actually isn't
necessarily to do with friendship it's
kind of like outside of that realm of
friendship and when it comes to
leadership and managing people a lot of
the time you don't bond and the deepest
connections that you have don't come to
do with anything to do with work because
work just gets you through the door it's
like if you don't turn up on time and do
the job that you're paid for you're
sacked like you put the book off like
you thought that is what gets you a seat
at the table
well actually it starts putting food on
the play is to do with well you know
what you like going to the gym I like
going to the gym why don't we do that
a man like I brought you a coffee in the
smile hey man did you watch it web don't
[ __ ] with cats on Netflix or like do not
I mean like that yeah that's what and I
say a lot of the time to the guys so I
run a nightclub business we have 400
staff that work for us I have 8 to 14
managers who are young guys and girls
you know between the age of 19 and 20 to
23 and they have a team of 30 to 60
people below them who've never worked
for anyone before they've just been let
go by mummy and daddy they party a lot
and we're trying to fill nightclubs
that's what we're doing it is the most
chaotic environment for a leader to try
and come into and these guys haven't led
[ __ ] they've they've literally just got
let go by their mom and their dad maybe
I'm about to bring on this is gonna go
out after I promote them so it doesn't
really matter I'm gonna bring four I'm
gonna bring em four new guys this week
I'm sitting down with them in two days
time and these kids came to university
one of the lads
is from America he can't even drink back
home and I'm gonna ask him to start
recruiting and managing a team but one
of the first things that I tell the guys
to do is
look if you want to get your team to buy
into you as a person and to do the thing
that they that you want them to do bond
about anything that isn't to do with
work as soon as you start talking to
them about even if it's just what's your
favorite drink things that are analogous
to work so oh well that's cool
like why don't we go out for a drink
then you can roll that into going out to
one of our events you know that's on the
side of things let's say that you're
doing a fitness business so why don't we
go to the gym let's say that you're
doing your in filmmaking or you know
like day trip whatever it might be like
taking an interest in someone in
everything that isn't work yeah pays
disproportionate dividends because they
categorize anything that is to do with
work they immediately lump it under like
one type of communication it's like oh I
might as well my even if it was a
whatsapp message it might as well be
[ __ ] email like but as soon as you
shift it out of that and you think well
this person actually cares about me
that's where and that's that analogy
between sort of that and vulnerability
it's like friendship actually gets built
around something which is got fuck-all
to do with friendship and a lot of the
good relationships that I've had best
relationships I've had with my staff
that have worked for me over the years
but absolutely nothing to do with what
we've achieved at work the achievements
at work have come of a byproduct of the
things that we've done outside of it it
is a it is a difficult line to get that
right so the way I kind of thought about
it is you very early leading a group
people have to work out the difference
between being friendly and friends
because if they become your friend and
your best mate where you're going out
together and you're you know chatting up
girls and go down the pista' going to do
whatever young people do this case the
next day like they don't turn up to work
you need to have a performance
management conversation or that
individual you need to be able to say
look that's unacceptable and I think
that knowing the boundary I think you
only know the boundary once you kind of
got it wrong or once you've overstepped
it with someone and you've become
friends with someone and you're like
yeah you know what that was a really
difficult person to have performance
management conversations with and maybe
they exploited a friendship a little bit
to kind of get away with some poor
performance dust
that's a tough one when you pull that
pin as well when you do the May we need
to have a chat when you do that it you
watch the walls of the friendship fall
down as well because sometimes people
might have thought I thought I was
getting special dispensation here I
thought that we were mate like it
doesn't stop the fact that we're not
maids it's not to do with the fact that
I'm not friendly but you are right the
war does get very muddied very fast and
in a business that may be a little bit
more bureaucratic than the one like our
soured the world of Club promo literally
is the Wild West yeah in a more typical
business organization people need to
they need to draw some incredibly bright
lines about what isn't is not sort of
acceptable friend behavior as well I
suppose
yeah and I think that's that's something
that it's probably slightly more unique
to your industry but at each industry
kind of has its own sort of lines on
sort of what success or I think provided
with Europe within your organization
your leadership is clear on what's
acceptable what's not acceptable and
then they all live in line entirely with
what is acceptable all the time that's
fine it doesn't matter where you draw
the line what matters is that there is a
line everyone was clear on what that
line is and there are consequences when
you step either side of it so I could be
I you know as a sort of young drew
cutter in the Marines I could get as
hammered as I want I could be up till so
the five o'clock in the morning you know
in in the centre of Taunton which is
graphics-based doing whatever I wanted
to do but at 8:30
I needed to be clean-shaven showered and
in front of my guys ready to do troopers
now if I was absolutely suffering and as
we went for a run I you know I was sick
obviously you don't do that every day
weirdly I would earn the sort of
probably an element of respect to doing
that but if you'd slept in your company
commander would come and kick it all
down like this is you would get that you
find that consequence real fast that was
totally unacceptable and again it's like
it's one of those that's that part of
the way
part of the culture for what that
organization was that worked really well
there might not work well everywhere
else but it doesn't really matter
everyone was clear on the expectation
and the standard don't you rod man this
has been awesome thank you thanks very
much now I've really enjoyed it great
great conversation so leadership forces
where working people go to find out more
yeah so leadership force is calm is my
website as with all websites as with me
it's a work in progress I do most of my
sort of thinking on written form on
there but I'm an open connector on
LinkedIn so don't bother personalize the
message it would be nice if you said you
listened to this podcast cuz it I know
where it came from but just hit me a hit
me up with a sort of connection requests
are always accept and always willing to
have a chat with people who think maybe
I can help them out whether that's
people from a commercial perspective but
equally anyone that is looking to
resettle out of the military I know how
difficult that journey is and I'll
always give people the time might not be
this week it might not be next week but
I'll always make time for a phone call
for anyone that wants it right awesome
man thank you very much you know what to
do
ladies and gentlemen like share and
subscribe links to what we talked about
today will be in the show notes below
but for now thanks for your time man
thank you
[Music]
you